الشتاء في اوكرانيا لم يجمدوا كل المعارك
لا توجد هناك هدنا محتمله في موسم الاعياد
موسكو وكيل تمتلكان العنصر البشري لكن
الامر مختلف بخصوص الاسلحه
الانتصار في بخمود سيكون اشاره قويه يرغب
زلنسكي من خلالها باقناع الغرب بقدرته على
قلب المعارك ولتحقيق الاهداف على الغرب
ارسال المزيد من الاسلحه اوكرانيا ترغب في
صواريخ بعيده المدى وانظمه دفاعا فعاله
لكن استخدام روسيا لورقه الضرب محطات
الطاقه يبدو انه اقنع واشنطن اخيرا بتقديم
بطاريات باتريات
اساسيا ومتقدم في دفاعات حلف النيته قبل
التواشنطن المخاطره فدخول باتريات ايضا
المعارك قد يجعلها تقع بيد الروس الذين
اعلنوا انها ستكون هدفا المشروعا ان وصلت
امر قد يتسبب في استنساخ التكنولوجيا او
حتى فقدانها لفاعليهتها
المخاطره الاخرى قبيلتها واشنطن اصاروخان
من باتريوت كلفتهما عاليه فمن 8 ملايين
دولار يمكن استخدامها في اعتراض هدفا واحد
مسيرات قيمتها 50,000$ وبالعوده الى بخموت
هنا مخاطره اخرى الطرفان يتبادلني الاف
القذف في المدفعيه يوميا انظمتها تريوت
الامريكيه او ايرس الالمانيه لا تتعامل
بفاعليه مع القذائف غير الموجهه ولذلك
وجودها على الجبهه سيجعله مواقع مكشوفه
وبالتالي يسهل تدميرها بطاريه واحده لن
تغير مسار الحرب وواحده لا تكفي ايضا
لحمايتك والمدن الكبرى وهذا هذا عن
تكلفتها نصف مليار دولار هناك مشكله اخرى
ايضا تشغيل النظام واحد يحتاج الى طاقه
يتكون من 90 عسكريا
فاكنا واشنطن لديها خطه للتدريب
[موسيقى]